[Music]
so
in the french riviera lies a medieval
town that's held one industry at its
very heart for the last 300 years
this is grass
this is the world's capital of perfume
this is the city of saints
[Music]
some of the big names that come from
here like chanel chanel number five
dior of course and louis vuitton it's
something that's understood here it's a
community it's a language it's something
that people share
[Music]
for example
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
the
[Music]
my name is jessica buchanan and i am an
independent perfumer
i came to grass for perfumery school
so what i do is in very simple context
mixing together raw materials for
various different uses whether it's a
perfume that one would wear to for
example a candle
[Music]
i think to create a good perfume i like
to allow six months to a
year this is a very creative process
when i sit in front of the perfumer's
organ
and create
it's like sitting in front of a piano
and composing music
yeah i think there's something in the
air here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
covering a half acre with hanging
flowers the oldest known wisteria in
japan is the centerpiece of this
brilliantly pastel colored flower park
[Music]
located in tochiki japan just over an
hour train ride from tokyo is ashikaga
flower park
the park spans 23 acres and is home to
more than 350 wisterias and other
flowers
the colors vary depending on the
flowering season from pinks and purples
to yellows and whites
some features of the park include the
wisteria tunnel and floating gardens but
the pride and joy of ashikaga flower
park is the great miracle wisteria
the 140 year old sprawling tree is
located in a place of pride right in the
center of the park
after nightfall the site is lit up so
these draping flowers can be seen at all
hours
the vivid yellow wisteria begins
blooming at the start of may and is the
only one of its kind in japan
the park is a year-round attraction with
seasonal plants that creates an
ever-changing sense of magnificence as
nature puts on a show
[Music]
[Music]
good
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and you'll actually go ahead and deploy
the forward ramp
so if there is a problem that's not too
stressed about it
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
every year about 8 million tons of waste
flowers are dumped into the indian
rivers
all the pesticides and insecticides that
were used to grow these flowers mixes
with the river water making it highly
toxic
we decided to do something about it
[Music]
indians depend on the river water for
drinking water for our agriculture and
for our basic needs
in hinduism we hindus go to temples and
offer flowers to our gods once these
flowers have been offered to our gods
they become sacred
they cannot be dumped in the dust
so according to religious customs they
are dumped into the river ganges once
these flowers have been dumped in the
river it creates havoc in the fragile
ecosystem of the water body
[Music]
we have decided that we want to solve
the flower problem but we didn't have a
solution
so we started going to temples begging
for the waste flowers but turned out no
one would trust us boys coming and
asking you for waste you're not sure
what they'll do with it
[Music]
so slowly and slowly we started with
around 12 kilos of waste flowers and in
a month we started collecting 80
kilograms of waste flowers
today our trucks go to the temple
directly collect these glaze flowers in
bins and bring them to our facility
we have a capacity of about 8.7 tons of
waste flowers per day
these flowers are treated to remove all
the pesticides and insecticides and
convert them into products
we make charcoal free incident sticks
bathing bars and now we are launching
biodegradable alternative styrofoam made
from these waste flowers
river ganges is the holiest river in the
world it says a dip in the river ganges
can remove all your sins
when i see river ganges in the state
that it is in i feel sad and i feel that
the status quo needs to be changed
you